[Music]
is this thing going
thank you thank you so much um
i would like to
[Music]
introduce my
beautiful beautiful cast
yuta wong lei singh
[Applause]
and kofi cerebo
[Applause]
the brains behind this
beautiful story felicia pride
[Applause]
my producers
aaliyah williams
[Music]
[Applause]
jones
[Applause]
we're gonna we're gonna bring out some
more some more chairs
and our exquisite moderator gil
robertson
[Applause]
how y'all
black people are as extraordinary and
normal at the same time it's beautiful
thank you
damn
so you're an artist we all are as far as
i'm concerned i just happen to paint i
don't have an artistic bone in my body i
find it hard to believe
[Music]
the power of your work comes from your
hunger so don't let this get in your
head and cause you to lose that
did you feel like you can't do that
i don't know
[Music]
thank you thank you so much
so now i want to talk about the genesis
of the project
i've known
i've known felicia for a very long time
and we've known each other and worked
together you know over the years
how did the two of you come together how
was this project born
uh we have a mutual friend producer
kelly thomas who also worked at film
independent i also worked at film
independent everybody is film
independent family um but she had been
trying to introduce us because we're
both from baltimore and felicia had just
moved to la and so we just so happened
to be at her barbecue at the same time
finally and we just started talking and
um she told me that she had written her
first screenplay and she was looking for
a director
and she described it as a love jones
meets blue valentine's set in dc and i
was like can you send it to me please
um and i read it like in one sitting and
then we had dinner and she was like i
want you to direct this and so that kind
of began
the journey
we were
you know both working full-time jobs and
we would get together after work
to
work on the script and we did that for
two years before we pitched it to macro
and so what was that process like
because i
vividly recall us having uh lunch
uh the organization that i were a part
of afka uh the african-american film
critics association we
uh had a partnership with uh
the project evolve program over at film
independent and it was something that we
were very excited about and i remember
you us going out to luncheon you're
telling me oh i'm leaving to make my
first movie
and it was just like something i mean we
were in hollywood having a hollywood
experience but now how does the project
find its way to macro and
uh talk about how you found these two
amazingly gifted talents
so i was on the set of lemert park
which is a series that
mel
and katie kamikate who's also in the
building
created and mel was directing so i was
on the set you know shadowing her and
aaliyah williams my producer and i we
walked down to the jamaican spot to get
some beef patties for the crew and she
was like um
you know what are you working on like
what are you doing and i said well i
think i found
the screenplay that's going to be my
first feature and so
she i described it to her
felicia's description again and she was
like send me that but i didn't want to
send it because it was mid-december and
everybody was about to you know
disappear from la
but something told me that saturday the
center of the script and the lookbook
right and i was like she'll get to it
when she does and that sunday morning i
had an email and a voicemail she was
like
so i wasn't going to read the script
but i looked at the lookbook and it was
so dope that i said let me just read the
first 10 pages she said i read the first
10 pages and i couldn't stop she was
like what are we doing so she gave the
script to
charles's wife who gave it to him and
then finally he called felicia nyen to
pitch the project but that's how it got
to macro the lovely stacy king
so now once the project got to macro how
did it get to you kofi and you uh utah
yeah
you trying to go first
ladies first um so initially i was
shooting um i was actually working on on
a completely different project not
really completely different love is um
so i was shooting that and i got
an um a request in my email about this
project and i saw
the script i was reading it i was like
wait a minute
honestly like you don't want to say it
out loud but i was actually auditioning
for
another part and i saw stevie's part and
i was low-key thinking to myself like
that
should actually be me
but you want to be grateful that you're
you know that you have the opportunity
to actually audition in the first place
so i was like you know what let me just
fall back i'll just audition
for
um for that other part and then you know
as
it always goes basically you don't hear
anything until two min two months later
and um
i got the request if i wanted to
audition for stevie i was like okay
so that's how manifestation works got it
loved it uh and i was ready to go i was
um i rounded up some of my buddies in
atlanta where we're shooting
and um
i really felt so much when i when i read
the script when i saw stevie's character
sometimes you're drawn to a character in
a way that just makes you feel
like you need to have it like this
really really strong urgency of like
wait a minute this might be that part
where you can
you know
sink your teeth in and that's what what
that was
and coffee
man
um
i think i was working on
season three of queen sugar
and uh you know i was also writing you
know i love to write and do my thing i
was writing a love story on my own and i
was really adamant about it you know and
then uh the conversation i really love
came about and similar to mel's
experience
let me see what they talking about you
know let me read these first 10 pages
that was it
like i couldn't stop reading it and um
i just related to isaiah you know just
the duality of being an artist
and wanting to succeed and find success
and evolve but at the same time still
needing love and wanting to just
love and be be in that space but um the
script was captivating macro is a
winning team
angel was just passionate she sent me a
crazy playlist she got me with that
spotify playlist that was cold
when does the playlist drop like the
soundtrack we you know
we're going to yeah give them the day
yeah they're not ready
i'm sorry nah but uh yeah i mean it's
just it's just like it was just it was
it was obvious and i guess for me
i was scared of the project at first
because it was so real you know like
isaiah just
it was like a mirror like i just saw so
much of what i was personally going
through in the film
and i was like
i don't know if i'm ready you know what
i'm saying
but that's how i knew i was i was ready
to do it i mean in a lot of ways the
both of the characters are are two young
individuals looking to find themselves
and find their place
uh find out who they are in this journey
but felicia as the
the artist behind the words behind the
story
how much of this mirror is your own
experience as a creative living in
baltimore looking to create a path
looking to find acceptance
you know for your work and your artistry
yeah i mean i was actually living in dc
and coming of age as an artist and for
those of you who know dc like it has
such a rich
culture so much history so much art but
then it also has like a very practical
side
so you have you bump up against that as
an artist
so that was kind of my experience and
then trying to date as an artist but
then also date as a woman like it was
just a lot so you know angel talks about
this a lot about seeing herself in both
characters and i can feel that right i
feel the plight of artists where
sometimes people don't understand how
consuming it is when you are trying to
create and also get on right
and then how you are trying to balance
and explain that to friends and family
and loved ones and then also wanting to
feel the things that you need to feel in
order to create
it's a lot yeah it is
but you pull it off so well and also the
thing with dc i mean
as i was telling you earlier i mean dc
and i remember you mentioning oh we're
going for doing it in belgium i remember
thinking
why baltimore
but i mean is that shade
but you feel the love you know when i
saw them walking coming out of the chili
dog house i was like okay i get it
you know this is part of the experience
that you wanted to get us to know but
talk about what it was like filming in
in both of your hometowns
um that part of it was magical i mean
we we everyone came to baltimore you
know baltimore isn't like a huge film
hub so
there were a lot of challenges for my
producers which they you know they
accepted gracefully but also we were
filming in neighborhoods where i grew up
like my grandmother's house is in the
film
um you know streets that i used to walk
home from school so
it was
it was beautiful to be able to come back
home
right and and make work because i've
been gone for so long and people know
that you're doing this thing
but then all of a sudden they can see it
up close and then they can participate
in it so it was just so much love like
you know to me and everybody involved
you know like my family
was bringing food to the house and you
know my producers frying chicken and we
eating crabs i mean that that piece of
it it just like we don't get to do that
when you're in a place like la or
elsewhere
we eating crabs
delicious
now utah and kofi
talk about how the two of you connected
and really you know
captured those roles
huh
what are you trying to say go man man
you too i'm only i'm only taking his
breath because she really she really
like again when i talk about the project
being a challenge she's a part of that
challenge you know she's an amazing
woman
she kind of just you know she just
ah
yeah
it's a great movie man it's a great
movie man
i'm not here i'm about to say no but to
be honest but to be honest it's like
making a film like this requires like a
really
you know real level of vulnerability it
really requires you to let let go of
some things and really you know
challenge some things and to do that
with someone it's like a relationship
like in real life you know so
i ain't know you two
we all know each other from nowhere like
we met on this project but we we
basically team up and say we're about to
do this and then it's like how you know
what's the actual like design like how
do we do this and you know you might hit
a few walls you know you gotta you gotta
you gotta work through some things and
usually it's personal but
when i sit here next to her now like i'm
just so blessed you know like i'm just
so grateful to have the experience to
like
experience her you know it's such a and
such a you know
you know go ahead talk let me stop
talking man
yeah
my cheeks hurt
no i'm just kidding um
so no i mean i i everyone knows kofi
it's like if you're like
into beautiful things you know kofi it's
like
but i just like i was very adamant in
like letting him know the first time we
met like listen you're not my wallpaper
and that kind of like
maybe that kind of you know made created
kind of like a wall in the beginning
but you were so i mean kofi is a
great actor first and foremost very
professional very intentional
and when we read the script i think both
of us realized that there was no way
that we're going to pull this off just
by being you know just by reading the
lines it was not going to happen we had
to like dig deeper and tap into
something that even in real life
is challenging to like you know reach
you don't want to be too vulnerable you
don't want to be too you know you always
have this
defense mechanism going on and that was
not possible for this movie so now we're
in this
in baltimore
you know we meet each other i'm like you
know let me just cook you some salmon
and see what's up
you know
and we talked about the script and we
really connected on a deeper level and
really made sure that
we both realized what the challenge was
you know and we just embraced it that's
what we did we really like dove deep and
made sure that you all felt it hopefully
angel and felicia how important was it i
mean one of the
the uh
things that certainly caught my eye in
watching was uh
the fact that this film uh
isn't you know wrapped around
trauma wrapped around
negative energy that it's wrapped around
you know uh possibilities and wrapped
around romance
and wrapped around hope
so um was that something important to
both of you as creatives in in getting
those messages out there you know uh
with stories about us
yeah i mean i think that it was
important at least i speak for myself to
be able to just show black people living
loving dreaming
fucking you know like all the things
that we do in our lives and like when we
center ourselves we don't think about
white people 24 7. we don't think about
racism 24 7 like we do we live and we
experience joy and we
um
but then we also are messy you know we
have our own hang-ups we have our own
blocks we have our own baggage that we
bring to things
so just showing us very complex very
complicated uh but also full and layered
um and and as for lack of a better word
like real and lived in an experience as
possible
and also to show like a range of black
people i think that was really important
especially if you go to dc you got
black people of all kinds across the
diaspora um and across class across
everything so being able to like put as
many of us into one space as we are in
our lives you know um was important and
you just definitely succeeded angel yeah
i mean it was very intentional i mean i
wanted i wanted to put on screen like
you know our lives like my friends you
know the relationships that we aspire to
you know what i mean i joke all the time
that like i'm equally both of these
characters you know what i mean like i
am the artist who puts every like her
work before everything but i'm also like
this woman who wants to be madly in love
you know what i mean so
all of those were very personal choices
so who you relate to more
oh here we go stevie is this the team
stevie or team isaiah question answer
that you ain't got to answer that
now of course everyone's looking for the
big movie moment they're looking for
uh that theatrical experience um
uh
what were your thoughts when you
realized that it wasn't going to
you know get that kind of play but
instead it was going to have the
opportunity to quadruple its audience in
fact by being on a streamer
i mean
you know i definitely had to uh have my
grieving moment with it right i mean i
think i always wanted to like experience
the film like this right with you all
but
i mean i think
when south by was canceled and i i was
the only one everybody was like are you
sure i don't think it's gonna happen
like my producers were like yeah no i
was like i'm gonna go
even if nobody else and then it got
cancelled and i was like
but
you know i think
right
but so many so so many things about this
film had like
at some point the film told us what it
wanted to do including like
when it wanted to reach its audience
right and so
i just have
constantly tried to like step back and
you know what i mean trust the process
because
now that it's coming out like
not even post pandemic right we can't
even say that yet but i think that um
you know if had it come out a year ago
or two years ago
like perhaps it wouldn't be received in
the way that it is right now so
i mean i used to work in film
distribution and i always talk about
like what your goals are right and there
are certain films that
luckily streaming has provided a new
outlet right and if we're talking about
bringing the film to the people
streaming is one a really great way to
bring the film to the people um and so
i'm really excited about the fact that
there's a potential for millions of
people to see this film like theatrical
can provide a beautiful communal
experience but it also provides
challenges and blocks and sometimes
you're in theaters for a short period of
time and then what happened so i'm just
excited about the global reach that this
film could possibly have
for real
[Applause]
excuse me uh folks are already talking
about
the continuation of these characters
that is so interesting i mean where do
you see
i'm really feeling part two
but what about the two of you where do
you see these two characters i think you
had a theory on that right i was just
gonna say i feel like we've been doing
the whole really love part two in real
life you know and take that how you want
don't don't go around with it you know
what i'm saying
but
naturally it was like we can't i mean
we're done like
the movie's finished like i still have
something like i still gotta figure
something you know i'm live on the table
you know and i said take it how you take
it you know don't be trying you know but
honestly like i don't
yeah that's what what what y'all huh
huh goofy
what's good being honest here yeah i
love it i think i think i think it's a
beautiful completion it's a complete so
even though it feels like it's
open-ended as a young artist of this
generation
that's how it be
you know
in real life i mean this is the writer
but i mean sometimes it's just it's all
these emotions it's highs it's lows it's
passionate and then it's nothing you
know you just have the moments and um
man thank god we still got you know we
still creating some moments you know
can we please remove the ladies to my
right
our producers over here
i mean i think everything you all did
was on purpose you know i just feel like
all of this was intentional but
definitely like i can agree with with
kofi it's like
you can't really
make something like that and just be
like well that's it
i mean this is gonna be a foundation for
life we don't know what's going to like
build what are we going to build on that
foundation might be part two
might be um
yeah
you know
no we actually we actually discussed is
we're going to like you know say some
crazy shit just for y'all but
i haven't seen him in years anyway wait
hold on if we gonna do this tell them
tell them what you what your dad said
tell him what your dad said
listen i just i just tell her like all
set like tell her what your dad said
cause i relate
you know what i'm talking about what are
you talking about
nice seriously don't know what you're
talking about
what my dad said like theater we either
we either getting married or what oh
that part yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
okay so my dad basically said okay so
you came back from baltimore
and uh obviously like art we we talk
about art imitating life life imitating
art but it was very obvious to like my
dad who's my best friend he was like you
came back and you're like a changed
woman
so you might want to like uh you know
you know figure some shit out and uh
i was like what i didn't even ask for
your for your opinion but thank you i
guess
but that just goes to say that um
this is like one of the
the same
feeling that i had when i read the
script
and the same feeling you had like it's
kind of dangerous like i'm not sure if i
want to go there and i think a lot of
actors saw this read the script and
actually said you know you might not
like
let's not go there because it's just
like
digging that deep as an actor you know
it comes with consequences and sometimes
you're stuck with someone for life it's
like okay
and uh yeah i think that's my answer
[Applause]
this is a weird q a
what's going on
this is this is what the people want
what you all joked out about what's so
funny
as creators angel and felicia how do you
feel about the comparisons to
an earlier class black classic film uh
steeped in romance black love
love jones how do you feel about those
comparisons i mean
that comparison blows my mind because
first of all love jones has been a
reference for me since i was 17. like i
saw that film on vhs tape and i hadn't
even been in love yet and i was like i
want someone to look at me like that so
for p anyone to compare to that is like
the highest compliment in my opinion
because that's like
one of my favorite films
and i i mean it was such a huge
inspiration i think about like two
things too like the music from from love
jones and the soundtrack and wanting to
bring that to this film and like infuse
music but then also like the love scenes
i remember like replaying i was in my
like over and over again with that
maxwell i was like jesus so like to see
that i hadn't seen that so intimate on
screen before and so that was really
important to put in the script of like
those type of that type of love making
like you know where she was like it
spoke to me you know what i mean like i
was like
so
yeah
oh
would you what
you found a compliment no way having to
occupy that space
[Music]
yeah i'm sorry can you hear me now
[Music]
what do you want the audience takeaways
to be
that's a great question i
you know for me
i want them to take away what i've
always felt like when i watch a love
story and when i walk away it's it makes
you think of your own love stories like
whether those are romantic or
you know platonic like i just want it to
remind
someone of
someone else like for me this is a love
story about two people
who
whether
right the story their love story
continues they are the the one person in
each other's lives who they will never
forget
um
i'll say that you know
i think also that
this film is about a wide type of love
and a wide-ranging love a self-love a
communal love a love of family a love of
dreams a love of art
so to be able to be thinking about those
things and connecting with those things
would be a joy if that would happen
i just want people to be inspired to
just dig deeper
you know whether that's art whether
that's love whether that's you know just
your personal relationship with self
just dig deeper like
it's so easy to watch a film or listen
to a song and just move on you know so
much going on but um kind of like how
you know
i want this to stick with somebody
forever you know for whatever reason
whether it's the music whether it's the
fashion whether it's youth you know it's
just
right i wanted to stick with people
forever you know
yeah i think um
to add on that like i feel like you know
it's easy to watch
it's not easy i mean you watch a film
but if you watch this film like so far
the the reactions and the responses i've
seen are that people
have
been
drawn into this story that really
makes them feel seen and heard
um
everyone's dealing with love it's just
like
or passion or just like the journey of
life i think nowadays we're so much more
aware of the fact that self-reflection
is key
and we all wonder if there's gonna be a
part two but it all depends on whether
or not stevie and isaiah come to like or
whether or not they're able to ascend to
a place where they can actually
love
and that's a space that's sacred and
it's a place that's not always hard it's
not always easy to get to but when they
do it could be magical
and we all get like a little hint of
that magic
in this film i believe
um and that's why i think everyone's
rooting for stevie and isaiah to like
actually make it so it's like i hope
that people get inspired to self-reflect
and to grow and to get to that space
where you can actually experience that
magic because i think we all really
deserve it you know and i was just gonna
say maybe it's not always about being
together
sometimes you just play a role in
somebody's life and that's the that that
was the point
you know so it's like
that inspiration that's priceless you
know that that ascension she's talking
about it's not always about
staying together it's like yo like
give me something you know give me what
i need you know
that's that's the hard part though
that acceptance right of
their their position or their role
but you know still still beautiful
you want to talk about it
i know i just
it wasn't it was on her she was it was
all on your face
we're getting some intel here tonight
but okay let's bring it back on track
let's
but talk about the music i mean the
music
uh
plays a significant role in this picture
um
you know talk about uh
how you set the musical direction you
know what went into that
yeah so i just want to shout out my
composer karim mateen again who's that
you need to stand up get up
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
you know it's um
i've always been intimidated by
scoring a film right because
it's like you don't know what the score
sounds like because it doesn't exist yet
but when i first sat down with carl
we've met in a coffee shop
and he
had you know looked at the materials and
um
we i talked i had an idea because i
wanted it to
feel like timeless and so
i just immediately like when i first
read the screenplay i thought horns like
i wanted to hear
horns and the score and then
when i sat down with him
he pitched the idea of like well
what if each of them has their own
instrument
and um so i was like okay
isaiah's instrument needs to be a horn i
thought it should be a sax but we landed
on the trumpet and kari is a cellist
and cello is my favorite instrument like
i was like stevie's instrument has to be
strings and so the way he approached the
score was
where are the moments where the
instruments play solo where do they play
together and when do they fight each
other
and so that's sort of like the direction
for every single cue
fire
[Applause]
the cinematography was also very
noteworthy
um
[Music]
what i mean and it was a situation where
we were photographed great i mean he had
no
was perfect lighting perfect
you could see the people and you can
appreciate their beauty
talk about that work experience with
your cinematographer
so sean peters is amazing um he actually
bought a house in baltimore after we rap
production
um
but just so
he loves black women he was raised by
black women and so
there would be moments where he would
say
utah's light isn't right
everyone stop you know like he was just
that intentional and meticulous
um and hans charles was
my camera operator howard alum um
he
you know just like
everything was so intentional um you
know
everyone was having conversations like
you know
my director photography with production
design and costume design and makeup and
hair so every we talked about like what
we wanted the palette to be and we
because we knew
when we knew that we would be in
baltimore in the summer and that it
would be humid it was like okay let's
embrace this humidity less i wanted
their skin to be dewy and you know we
wanted to use color
to align with like what was happening
emotionally and um you know sean really
got in my hand and and helped us you
know develop a language
i mean that's like that's a technical
approach i mean not really technical but
from a from an actor's perspective
it was such a treat to be on set and
actually having people around you
in every single department that really
care and are
actually aware of the fact
that your skin is black
you know
it seems such a
it's not really trivial obviously it's
not
but it was so beautiful to actually see
shawn
think about what lens would work best
for kofi you know to make him a little
bit more handsome or whatever you know
or for me you know
to tone it down a little bit so i could
like you know get closer to his
visuals so it was like that was like the
fact that
troll
yeah no sir no but um no but actually i
love the fact that he was so conscious
of all of those different things and
then you have the hair department stop
makeup everything and it just it just
felt like a dream to work on a set
where you could actually be you know
like in your full potential and you know
a lot of times it's just like okay so
we're just gonna stick your hair back
with some water like
you're gonna need more than that
and it's like you know but you're kind
of in like a weird position you don't
wanna like you can't really talk about
it and then you feel like you're the
diva like you know you need an extra
person coming to set but this just gave
me the space and i think that goes for
you as well to like actually focus on
what you're trying to do which is tell
this story
so um yeah i mean just adding on that a
little bit and then i also you know
because
the film is you know about this painter
i was like i want every frame to look
like a painting i wanted it to be you
know like composed and there are moments
in the film where it's like hand held
but those are we were very intentional
about where those would be
you know um but i wanted everything to
kind of
mirror like the paintings that he was
making so we were trying to like create
like a composition that felt like
something that he would paint
wow
talk about uh the film independent your
film independent experience and how how
it helped prepare you for this moment
i mean
so many uh relationships from film
independent helped me make this film so
many i mean um
yeah i mean it's like where do i begin
you know like
mel aaliyah film independent fellows
shawn's film independent fellow my
editors film you know what i mean so
just so many
you know uh felicia took the the
screenplay through the screenwriting lab
you know what i mean so they have been
involved in every stage of the process
you know with the screening they're
hosting this screening because they
support us
you know so
[Applause]
yeah we we have so much love for film
independent and you know when they
when they support you they they never
stop and um that's always been the case
so i'm very proud to be like both an
ex-employee as well as a fellow
so
where can how do we follow how do we
continue this journey let's go to i mean
the social media tags
black twitter black twitter is lit
yeah
how do we offer our comments about what
we agree or disagree with or what we
want to see next go around
twitter it's
yeah it's um
really love that's how yep
really love everywhere okay and also
strong black lead um yes strong black
lead on instagram and twitter has been
just amazing in terms of the holding the
film down supporting the film creating
content around the film so they already
have conversations that they have
started and are
um so look for more content from there
as well
and i and i cannot leave the building
without just acknowledging suzanne
douglas who
like every time
there's there's so many spirits that
touch this film and she is a is a huge
part of that and so every time i see her
face like it just
it makes my heart full and i feel so
grateful and blessed to have met her
and um
to have her be like this through line
for the film
she's just so magical
was this her final role
i believe so yeah i believe so
wow
well everyone thank you for coming uh
really love is on netflix right now make
sure you watch it
thank you guys for coming
thank you thank you for coming everyone
[Music]
you